my name is Lucia converse research and
yes this is a joint talk this is my part
and then my colleague Eduardo will be
talking about point processes and I
start with a little introduction what do
we have and we are interested basically
in in working with collections of points
of some observations you may think about
tracing the forest you may think some
positions of the stars the point is that
the idea is the observations are points
and we can think about the locations as
you know the rest of vectors of length
to so we have x and y coordinates and
what we want to have in our container
for the special unit point data is not
just location but also the greater
observational window because the fact
that the location exists or locations do
not exist is also important because the
absence of observations is also of
importance so the definition for the
special point data is to provide
locations provide the location so the
list of locations and provide as the
second argument the observational window
so here this is locations is just a
sample random Rio the the reals between
0 & 1
and we look at the window which is the
rectangle and this is special point data
which is a constructor and also a
container and there is some information
in the elided formula you see the number
of points you see the dimensions you see
them we see the region bounds and
because this is the rectangle we got the
0 once and when you expand that you can
you can you know get some more
information more information can also be
obtained by expanding the properties
this is the list of these properties I
will show some of them and some of them
are self-explanatory but
I'll talk a bit about them later so what
we can do special point data what I
think the main thing people want to do
is to plot it so for this for this
two-dimensional set the least plot is
the good candidate to plot special bond
data we can also put together a region
plot with our list plot plot the
observation window with the points there
is also situation that we don't have
specified observation window and in this
case the the there will be an estimated
observation region computed when the
when the special point data is defined
which is the refugio son estimate and
this is an example for our locations at
the beginning and this that this is the
region and so you see that this is one
of the users to access the properties to
check the region and this is the plot of
our original window which is the the
unit square the estimated region and the
points within we can also define special
point data in 3d I only have here
locations the three-dimensional
locations and visualize with the least
point free D and this is the estimated
region observation window for this 3d
data we would like to also provide a
support for the geo locations because a
lot of information is coming from mobs
and Geographics so special poon data
also works supports geo locations this
is the new function random geo position
so just have 100 random points around
the world and we can store them and you
see that right now that the region
bounds will correspond a bit to the to
the latitude and longitude bounds and
the way to visualize that right now is
to for example use geo least plot it
will take the points from the from the
spatial foundation another example this
is using the information which exists in
a foreign language in
entity framework I have a country which
is Armenia and I ask for the largest
cities and then I asked for two
properties of this largest cities which
is name and position and what I do here
I create special point data which takes
a rule so I pack all the positions in a
single geo position and then I assign
what we called marks so there are
special features of each position and
create the special point data the region
was estimated that's the polygon on from
there from the Geo positions but we can
also specify a region as the whole
country and put this as the observation
region this is the cities to definition
and then the region as you can see here
this gonna be much the polygon it's much
more precise in that way so the points
as you see I actually used the G of
position but even if you give the wrist
of geo positions the points will be
stored in a compact form of the Geo
position the position had so if we want
to then do something with the points
would need to fret this geo position and
this is an example of creating a
tooltips where I have on the on the
first the location and then the name and
I what happened was that we created this
special point data or giving the names
and that can be extracted asking for
marks and then give the name of this of
this mark and then use the goog list
plot with less tooltips and then you can
see that each point has a tooltip of the
name of the city another application is
to get the information about the nuclear
reactors in the world and that's again
from the entity value and I take two
properties here this is a position and
animal energy production and we create
in a similar way we create special point
data with the geo positions rule those
two marks which will be the production
information
we have the special point data the way
to visualize in this case where we have
actually a lot of them the number of
points you see it's 424 would be to use
geo histogram that gives us a better
plot to see this what we can also do
with the special point data is to select
a certain point make a subset put it
that way and so this is a special point
select and what I want here is to select
only the reactors that lie in the United
States so I select them by providing the
region I'm gonna select by the region
and then what is my region is the
polygon of the United States and then
what what I use here is a geo bubble
chart where that's a location and then a
rule then we have the marks that give us
the production and so each bubble will
tell you the number for the for the
production on the owner each location
for the other of the reactors ok another
example this is pre curated data it's
the there's some sinkholes and and
springs in in in Ozarks and so we
already have the data and would like to
know a bit more about this so we can
plot so this is a Geo list plot
basically on the special point data but
we can also take into account you know a
bit more information so to plot the
background is the the state in which
this is so this is Arkansas and also the
observation region this is this
rectangle on top of this in the north of
the state one of the properties of the
of the special point data it's the mean
intensity which gonna be the number of
points divided by the by the measure of
the of the region so this is kind of we
know how many cars features will have
per square mile
the region in this case that that was
the plot at rectangle that's the geo
bounds region and if you want to know
some more about the how big the region
is in terms of human units so miles you
know kilometers we can kind of extract
the corners and then compute geo
distance on the on the corners so we are
talking
about you know 220 miles across one of
the questions that it's being asking
this you know point the special point
locations analysis is how far you know
like how far was the probability to go
from one feature to find the next
feature like the closest feature we need
by which is called the nearest neighbor
and this is nearest neighbor G function
which is the the CDF for the nearest
neighbor distribution and we can compute
for example the the plot of this in so
that's the probability to find another
feature within you know one mile two
miles and such and also using some
approximation of the of the integral of
the 1 minus the CDF we can compute the
mean distance from a typical feature to
its nearest neighbor which is 0.76 miles
and this is a bit cheating because this
is a prototype visualization function
which probably will never exist in info
from language but it exists now to help
us to plot these features especially
when we don't yet have the properties
visualization function that would do
this and this splits the data because
you see the data actually had two
categories that were there were Springs
and there were sinkholes and we didn't
talk about that but this plot will kind
of reveal that but also the other
information the other way to assess the
information is to go to the summary
property that will tell us about
existence of marks
so here the the the mark is to the karst
feature and we can again use the special
point select to extract just the
sinkholes when justice Springs and we
can compare intensities using the geo
smooth histogram for them and points and
then brings us to you to my my last
slide which is kind of a bit
introduction to that the Eduardo's part
of the talk is that a special point data
is also container for simulation data
from the point processes
so we introduced some point processes
Hyrum
I'm having an example of the pissant
point process of intensity 1:50
dimension to over a rectangle and when
we simulate that using the random point
configuration we get a special point
data we can plot this another example is
to have a cluster point process one of
such processes is Mattern point process
when we have intensity of the clusters
intensity in for for a cluster the
radius and also the dimension and then
we also obtain special point data and
that concludes my part hi my name is
Edna I've been working with Garcia in
one spatial point data and spatial point
processes we've been doing we've been
putting a lot of work both on the data
side and the container side of of the
problem so what Kirsch has been showing
being able to manipulate data being able
to visualize it being able to extract
statistics from it these things are very
important and we've also been putting a
lot of work into the modeling sites of
of the problem which is what I'm going
to be work talking about
you'll never know okay so let me just
motivate why we I mean this is an
obvious thing but I think it's worth
saying again in statistics and in
science we want to model data and for
that we we use outside knowledge prior
information that we didn't extract from
the problem that but where we perhaps
have like reasons to believe that
there's an underlying mechanism to the
problem or something like that and we
this enables us to do two things
enables to make more powerful
predictions and it also enables us to
learn something about the the underlying
mechanism that we're trying to that
we're trying to understand so it's a
two-way process and that's why modeling
is so important for possum four point
processes there's many many types of
models we it's impossible to to to
include them all really there are large
families that we have tried to include
but and there's still some missing now
we hope we we can include but this is
like a huge space the the the the stuff
we have so far
falls into three main families they're
the Poisson family which are there were
points they points generated by the
processor are independent from each
other
then we have very big family of model
school we can call interactive models
where they're not in the one then no
independent from each other and this can
be this can model all types of
interaction second-order so only
pairwise interactions for more
complicated stuff they we also ask
osseous showed in a Last Light have
cluster processes which are a subset of
the above because they're interacting
processes but they have their own they
they can be specified in a natural way
by specifying the centres of the
clusters and then the the cluster
generating mechanism and
again there's many more there's some
coke stochastic processes and and this
the it's it's a never-ending thing may
we have we have some some general
processes that can generate large
families of these given their very very
general and then we have more dedicated
processes that have dedicated algorithms
that are more efficient but they're less
general
so let's talk about the Poisson process
that goes to introduced this is the
simplest one and it's in many sense in
many ways the more the more important
one because it's the the one we we
compared against a when we first
encountered eight-way this is the one
where points are uniformly distributed
over the observation region and they're
also independent from each other this
last condition the independence
condition is very important and it
requires that the number of points is
not fixed and in particular its person
distributed by the the non fix this
parts are important if we if the number
of points was fixed like you would get
for instance using their the function
random point in the Wolfram language and
because the number of points is fixed
different sbrick the number of points in
different sub-regions would depend on
the number of points on other sub
regions and by definition there wouldn't
be independent so that's the reason why
we need a process of a process which
whose points are fully independent needs
to have a non fixed number of points as
course I said they its defined by the
intensity which is the mean number of
points per unit of measure of the region
and we also specify the dimension here
so in this case dimension two and on the
plane M we again this is the same there
of course it did previously we can
specify a region it's time a disk and we
can sample from it and we can plot it
and this is what porcelain point process
looks like with this type of intensity
some this big we can see this big gaps
we can see that some points are very
close to each other
this is this is what it looks like yes
yes the intense the density intensity
there's a linear transformation yeah
yeah there's a thing called a binomial
point process that we also have that
specifies the number point but then as I
said before that the number of points is
not independent if you look at one one
one half disk the number and we count
the number of points we will know how
many points we have on the other side
and that's that's no fully independent
so so this is why this is the simplest
point process yeah that was that was
luck yeah yeah the number of points is
portion distributed times the intensity
times the region measure that's that's
how you generate them actually so
although this is a very simple model it
can reasonably model very real a real
world data and if we don't have a good
reason to believe that the point that
their data is has been generated by a
more complicated model this is the right
thing to do you you don't want to over
complicate things you don't want to over
fit data so this is this here SPSS data
that we have taken from one of the
curated sets that we have I plot it
again it looks something like this
notice that it doesn't quite look the
same as why I had here like you can
visually see that something's not the
same but to a first approximation we can
do a spatial randomness test which is
essentially testing our data is a quote
is distributed according to a Poisson
process of any lambda of any intensity
and we can see that this test
passes and we can estimate the process
and we get an intensity of point zero
zero six nine I'm gonna I'll come back
to to testing in a bit we also have the
inhomogeneous Poisson process which is a
very general object and it's the older
brother of the Poisson process M and
here post points are independent but
they're not uniformly distributed this
is a very general object that can
impractical most types of data because
you can use an arbitrary intensity
including on parametric estimation again
if you don't have a good reason to
suggest their interactions of something
more complicated going on this is a this
will will do for your needs so here an
example is I I used this intensity to
the intensity I and it's very steep it
will it and we can define then
homogeneous Poisson process again with
the intensity in the dimension like we
did before the for the for the
homogeneous one we can sample and we can
show that indeed the density or the
intensity of points is heavily skewed to
veer to the north east north northeast
because here the density is gross
more quickly in there in the y-direction
we can also estimate this this intensity
on parametrically so we intensive
estimate the using we have a function
called smooth point intensity but we
also have discrete versions of this
function that used different types of
binning and we and this works this is a
valid intensity that you can put in
there process and again sample and it
all works perfectly and you'll be use it
you'll be able to use it like it was a
function
so here's the plot that shows the the
contour plots of the envy of the
nonparametric intensity the and the the
parametric sample that we generated
above in the nonparametric example okay
okay
so let's talk about point process that
it's slightly more interesting this is
this is the the simplest perhaps of the
interacting processes and it's called
the whole point process and it's like a
Poisson process but with an with an
intensity lambda but points are not
allowed to be closer than a radius R of
each other so this can model actually
lots of things this is also very useful
model you can trees anything that will
there will be like an exclusion a
hard-core exclusion between the points
and here we set the hakurei's to be
point one we sample from it and we
compare here's a plot to compare between
the earlier Poisson point process the
uniform or in the homogeneous one in the
hard core and we can see that the that
the orange points are never too close to
each other are useful this is a
something called a Frey plot which is
which computes the points at distances
between pairs of points and it's useful
to to to visually determine whether
there's a hard core because they'll be
like you can see then in the center
there's like a kind of perfect circle in
the middle and this is shown and and
this won't happen if it's not like a
pure hardcore
so coming back to testing we yeah we can
see we can again do a spatial randomness
test with these points generated by a
haiku poem process and we can see that
the first that the first test that the
full test passes the test which is and
we know it's not spatially rightfully
special random because we generated and
it's a hardcore point process so and
this is because this test the default
test this for now it's very fast but
it's not it doesn't have a lot of power
but if they use a more powerful test
this is we've call it the one to Carla
for now I use Monte Carlo simulation
using a more discerning so that this
they call the bestower Gail statistic
this one's able to very clearly figure
out that the p-value for this is zero
and we can tell that it's not fully
independent we can also estimate the
parameters for this process nor some
process have it's very hard to estimate
the parameters for for mathematical
reasons of ambiguities and they're not
the estimation is no webhost problem but
for some we can and we do in this case
we estimate that the indeed that the
hardcore is very close to 0.1 and it has
the intensity of 31 which it was 30 we
can plot this estimated point process
again the the the plot looks the same
looks good and we can more importantly
estimate if this check if this estimated
model is a good fit for the data that we
had and this is a very powerful test you
know this has a lot of power if it's not
it will quickly give you a very because
it's using again these distant
statistics and it's using a Monte Carlo
simulation so the fact that this is the
fact that this test passes is a very
encouraging thing you found data and you
test passes it is very
encouraging thing that you've you you're
doing something right there your model
fits the data reasonably well we can try
with a porcelain point process and it
won't it won't be a good fit we estimate
the intensity the intensity is different
and the the the p-value is is very small
and and this is rejected at the 5% level
okay I need to rush need to finish okay
so let me just give an application using
the process or something fun that you
can do is imagine if this was a forest
we we figured out the the radius the
hard core radius before how much could
we pack this forest so he analytical
calculations important important process
are very hard to do but we could we can
sample we can obtain your medical
results quite easily so so we could say
okay let's sample let's keep the hard
core radius the same crank up the
intensity take loads of samples and we
can get a histogram of the Poincare
distribution and the maximum of of the
number of number of trees that we can
fit in this region with this with this
hard core constraint so we we sample a
thousand realizations we this ones the
first this plot the orange one is the
plot of the or the first of these
realizations for that for the packed
case and we can see that the points
still obeying the hard core constraint
but they're much closer than in the than
in the the previous hard core sparse
case where the intensity was lower we
can take a histogram other point counts
and we can see it's kind of like a
Gaussian ish shape or Poisson and we we
can see a maximum that it's reasonable
here it's 182 trees okay so I'm gonna
finish because we have to finish to
conclude this is upcoming functionality
we'll be able to work with spatial point
data and spatial processes we leverage
all the geographical and geometric
functionality that's already present in
the phone and they Wolfram language so
we can do arbitrary regions and you know
this is very important and that's it